ein aspekt der erst in jüngster zeit
thematisiert wird sind die übergriffe
von wehrmachtssoldaten auf die weibliche
polnische bevölkerung quellen sind
hinsichtlich sexueller gewalt insofern
immer schwierig als das wäre von einer
hohen dunkelziffer ausgehen müssen nicht
jeder übergriff kommt zur anzeige da
spielen punkte wie scham eine rolle dass
es sicherlich ein punkt wir haben in den
besetzten gebieten und vor allem im
besetzten polen dann noch mal die
zusätzliche verschärfung dass eine
anzeige gegenüber einem deutschen ganz
ganz drastische konsequenzen nach sich
ziehen konnte für den polnischen kläger
das regiment von weiter kämpft die
meiste zeit in vorderster linie es dort
fast eine woche bis seine einheit eine
pause erhält endlich findet der
unteroffizier zeit nach hause zu
schreiben
mein liebling wir haben den krieg mit
allen strecken kennen gelernt
unaufhaltsam geht der vormarsch weiter
so mancher kamerad von uns musste ins
gras beißen
wer weiß mein schatz ob wir uns wieder
sehen
ich glaube es nicht dein lieber walter
die hat sich im keller versteckt
lasst sie laufen heute mittag waren wir
in einer mühle die müllerin haben wir
ganz verstört aus dem keller gezogen
wir sehen das die wehrmacht im beim
einmarsch nach polen sexuelle
gewalttaten verübt also einzelne
mitglieder der wehrmacht aber auch
einzelne mitglieder der einsatzgruppen
der sicherheitspolizei et cetera
das sind oftmals gruppen vergewaltigung
und wenn man hier soziologische
erklärungen heranzieht wird oft
argumentiert dass das eigentlich eine
vergemeinschaftung dient also mann
verübt so sagen man eine verbrecherische
tat das schweißt die kleinen gruppe
zusammen die dann weiter in diesen
verbrecherischen krieg agiert
september 1939 in der südpolnischen
stadt klötze aufmachen hausdurchsuchung
fünf soldaten dringen in das haus einer
eisenbahnerinnen sie wollen kindern
doch dann fällt ihnen die 16 jährige
tochter auf die soldaten betrachten die
polnische bevölkerung als freiwild
gemeinsam vergewaltigen sie das junge
mädchen
[Musik]
die fälscher emery hat begonnen zu
ermitteln und die soldaten haben das
sehr bezeichnend ist zu protokoll
gegeben dass sie davon ausgegangen sind
dass das ihr gutes recht sei oder dass
sie zumindest straffrei davonkommen
würden und waren recht überrascht dass
sie dann doch in die fänge der fälscher
einen namen re gerieten aber ob die
soldaten jetzt abgeurteilt wurden und in
welcher form erschließt sich nicht